today's video is a practical beginners
guide to building desktop apps with
electron by the end of this video you
will built a desktop app that's
installable on Mac OS Windows and Linux
using nothing but HTML CSS and
JavaScript you'll learn how to combine
api's from the web no js' and electron
to build a desktop screen capture it
created some native menus captures a
video stream from your system and can
write the raw video file to your
filesystem now if you have no idea how
electron works make sure to check out my
100 seconds of code video on that topic
if you're new you're like and subscribe
and grab the full source code for this
project on fire ship IO now Before we
jump into the code and turn you into an
electron developer there is one thing
you should know a lot of people like to
talk [ __ ] about electron and to be
honest a lot of the criticism is valid
electron apps bundle chromium and nodejs
out of the gate and that tends to lead
to a very large app size even for a
simple app on top of that running
chromium can be a resource intensive so
your app will probably use more CPU and
RAM than a comparable app and
objective-c or a c-sharp but here's the
thing these drawbacks don't matter very
much for most developers when it comes
to the big picture
is fun fun I do bad things if you're a
web or nodejs developer electron offers
an amazing developer experience and it
makes desktop apps a practical business
decision for companies that would
otherwise not consider them even big
companies with tons of talent and cash
still choose electron because it makes
more business sense at the end of the
day the only thing that matters is that
you build an awesome user experience
which you can absolutely do with
electron and your users don't know or
care what technology you use to build
the app I think Winston Churchill said
it best electron is the worst desktop
architecture except for all the others
we've tried now that we have that out of
the way
let's take a closer look at the desktop
app we're building today it's a simple
screen recorder it takes one of the
windows that you have opened on your
desktop and turns it into a video stream
and then we preview that video stream in
our electron app when we click the
record button it will turn the stream
into an actual raw video file when you
click stop it will open another native
menu this time asking where you want to
save the file output and lastly it
writes the raw file to your system so
this will be a really fun project
because you'll need to use node.js for
certain things web technologies for
other things in electron api's as well
this tutorial is designed for you to
follow along but we'll be moving at a
very quick pace so feel free to pause or
slow down the playback
to get started what first want to
generate some initial boilerplate code
to do that I'll be using an awesome tool
called electron Forge along with it's
option for plain vanilla JavaScript but
if you have a preferred framework
there's all kinds of starter projects
out there that you can use and the code
in this project should be relatively
easy to port over to one of those step
one is to open up the command line and
run npx
create electron app with the name of
your app go ahead and open that up and
you'll see electron Forge has given us a
little starter project that's nice and
all but towards the end of the video
we'll look at how electron Forge can
help us build the actual distributable
is that people can install on their
system now if we open the source
directory you can see we have an index
HTML and CSS the HTML is the entry point
to our front-end UI or the render
process then we have index J s which is
the entry point to our main process at
this point let's go ahead and fire up
the app to make sure it's working run
NPM start from the command line and it
should launch the application on your
system now one thing to keep in mind is
that it doesn't do hot reloading like
you might be used to if you work with a
web framework if you make some changes
and want to see them reflected in the
app come down here to the command line
type in RS in the same terminal and your
app will restart let's open up this
index.js file to take a closer look at
how electron works every electron app
has exactly one main process which is
created by this index.js file up here at
the top you can see we're importing two
things from electron app in browser
window app is used to control the
lifecycle of the app and it uses an
event based API let's take a look at
some examples the main event we want to
listen to is ready so we say app on
ready run this function this event will
fire once when the app is actually ready
and you can run whatever initialization
logic you want here now electron Forge
already set this up for us but feel free
to implement your own logic here if we
look below that you can see we're
handling a couple of other events as
well like window all closed because
Mac's have different operating system
behaviors than Windows you can run
platform specific code by checking the
process platform value this is a special
value provided by electron and if it's a
Mac it'll be Darwin or win32 for Windows
so our app has one main process but it
can have multiple render processes going
at the same time a render process is an
instance of chromium so you can think of
each render process as being a tab or
window in the browser we create one by
instantiating a browser window and
there's a bunch of different options
we can pass here but I'm going to set
the node integration to true that allows
us to access node.js Global's directly
in our front-end code so that gives us
an empty browser window now we use load
file to load our index.html into it if
we look at the HTML you can see it's
nothing but a hello world in fact we
don't even have any JavaScript running
on our front-end yet let's change that
by creating a file called render Jas and
then we'll add a script tag pointing to
that file here in our HTML and make sure
to use the defer attribute so the script
loads after the HTML while we're in here
I'm going to go ahead and add Bulma CSS
to the head of the document as well
that'll make our UI look a little more
polished then down here in the body
we'll add a video element to preview the
actual output that's being recorded down
below that we'll add three buttons the
first button will start recording the
second button will stop recording and
the third one allows us to choose the
actual video source from the system now
let's jump into our render js5 if your
web developer you can think of this as
your friend end code and it has access
to everything that you would expect in
the browser let's start by simply making
a reference to the HTML elements in the
Dom we can use document query selector
to grab the video element and then we
can grab our three buttons by using
document get element by ID
our first challenge is getting access to
all of the available screens on the user
system to record luckily electron has a
desktop capture module that we can use
right here in our render process let's
go ahead and import the module using
require electron actually makes the
require function available in the
browser now that we have that imported
we'll go ahead and set up a custom async
function called get video sources and
we'll assign this function as the event
handler when our video select button is
clicked in the function body we can get
access to all of the windows or screens
in the system by calling desktop
captured get sources this method returns
a promise so we'll need to use the await
keyword to await the actual value the
value is an array of objects where each
object is a window or screen available
on the user's computer that we can
record and now that we have access to
this data we just need to implement some
kind of UI element for the user to
select the screen they want to record
that'd be a good use case for a native
popup menu
electron has a menu class but it's
actually designed to run on the main
process we can access things on the main
process using a module called remote
this is one way to handle inter process
communication
or IPC it's a very important concept but
all you need to know for now is that it
allows us to build native menus directly
in our front-end code here we'll set a
variable for the menu itself and then
we'll call menu build from template this
method expects an array of objects where
each object represents a different menu
item in an easy way to create that array
is with JavaScript array map method to
convert our array of input sources into
an array of menu items for each source
we'll return an object where the label
is the source name and then we'll
register an event handler for click that
calls another function that we have not
yet implemented yet called select source
and lastly if we simply call popup on
this menu now if we restart the app and
click that button you can see it gives
us a list of all the windows on our
system at this point clicking on an item
doesn't do anything that's because we
need to implement our select source
function this will also be an async
function and the first thing we do in
here is set the inner text of our video
select button - the name of the source
then to capture video from the source we
need to set up a few options here we'll
set audio to false and then we'll set
the chrome media source to desktop and
the Chrome media source ID to the source
ID we pass to the function from here
we'll use the browser's built-in
navigator API to create a streaming
video we can await navigator media
devices getusermedia with the constraint
options that we defined before this will
provide a stream of video output of
whatever's happening in that window so
all we have to do is grab our HTML video
element and set its source object to the
stream we'll click Play and that should
give us a real-time feed of the window
go ahead and restart the app and then
select a video source this time you
should see a real-time preview of the
video feed in your electron app ok so
now that we have a stream of video
footage from the user's system how do we
record it and then save it as a video
file that we can then play back one way
is to use the browsers built-in media
recorder I'll set the recorder up as a
global variable and then set an empty
array for the recorded chunks this would
allow you to potentially record video in
multiple segments from there we'll go
back down to our select source function
and we'll set up options for the mime
type on the media recorder then it will
instantiate the media recorder class
passing at the stream as the first
argument now the recorder can be
controlled by the user and it has an
event based API
there are two events that we care about
here on data available and onstop will
define handlers for these events as
separate functions
when the video data becomes available we
want to simply grab it and push it to
our recorded chunks array that's easy
enough but when the recording has been
fully stopped we want to take those
recorded chunks and convert them into a
video file we do that by creating a blob
and a blob is essentially just a data
structure to handle raw data like a
video file but what's kind of confusing
is we don't actually want to blow up
here we want a buffer which is also an
object for representing raw data we
create the buffer by calling buffer from
and then awaiting the blobs array buffer
I realize that's pretty weird but it's
just what we have to do to get the data
in the proper format to be played back
as video but now that we have this raw
data we need to give the user a way to
select where they want to save it on
their system electron has a very
powerful dialogue module that runs on
the main process so we can import that
from our remote module it allows us to
easily create native dialogues to do
things like save and open files in this
case we'll wait show save dialogue which
will resolve to the file path that the
user has selected we can customize the
button to say save video and then we'll
set up a default path that timestamps
the video and now that we have the user
selected file path we simply need to
write that file to the system and we can
do that of course in nodejs with the
built-in FS or file system module it's a
node module so we'll need to require it
and the function we're interested in is
write file we can come down here and put
it to use by passing at the file path
and then the buffer as the argument for
the raw data it's a callback based API
so we can pass in a third argument as a
function that will just console.log that
the video was saved successfully and
we're done your desktop app is now a
fully functional screen recorder but I
did promise you one more thing and
that's to package the app for different
operating systems like Mac Windows and
Linux
sounds pretty hard well not so much
electron Forge basically does all this
for us automatically out of the box
open up the terminal and run npm run
make it will automatically detect your
operating system and then build the
distributable for that OS I happen to be
on Windows right now so when I run this
command it creates an out directory and
then you can find the executable in here
to run your application natively I'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
I think the key takeaway here is that if
you know JavaScript then you can start
building desktop apps today and if you
want to see more project-based videos
like this on YouTube make sure to LIKE
and subscribe
and leave me a comment down below thanks
for watching and I will talk to you soon
[Music]